après corinne thierry claudine auger la
troisième j'aime ce bond girl française
possède aussi un pagne en commençant par
un c'est carole bouquet 24 ans
championne d'arbalète moment vous étiez
au conservatoire est ce que vous pensiez
qu'un jour vous vous trouveriez dans un
film américain de 25 millions $
oui
au départ j'avais pas de doute je
voulais le faire je savais que j'allais
vivre
vous entrez un jour au conservatoire un
total hasard
oui vous en êtes parti je suis partie
renvoyer comme ça vous êtes entré dans
le cinéma
encore une fois un petit peu par hasard
par accident
je crois pas que je ne sais pas ce que
je voulais mais en même temps aussi par
accident mais ça je crois que c'est la 4
un peu la grâce aux compétences yeuse
mai et des gens qui rendent quelque part
et puis ça c'est les gens s'arrêtent
regardent
quelle que soit la que c'est pas une
question de définition du nez des yeux
c'est autre chose
50 le nez les yeux sont bien ça c'est
pas normal ça fait pas de mal mais ça
c'est sûr que je vais pas m'en plaindre
mais ne vérifiez pas elle a débuté sous
la direction de luis bunuel puis de
bertrand blier
c'est une drôle de gymnastique de passer
des films vidéos films d'action dans des
décors exotiques ou voltige les flèches
les hélicoptères et même les voitures
vous plaisir il est autant longtemps
dans l'iphone
voilà le plaisir de jouer on peut le
trouver que ça se voit avec monsieur
bunuel ou sur un nom sur un james bond
surtout parce que je trouve qu'un james
bond est une chose mythologique pour moi
vraiment alors c'est pas du tout
simplement un film d'action c'est aussi
un mythe un mythe amis du 20e siècle
c'était pas grave d'être envoyés du
conservatoire il suffisait de savoir
nager
il est profondément